Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test
to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do.
We'll take your sword
and deliver killing
blows on this boar carcass.
Jonathan, you're up first.
You ready?
Go for it.
So a boar has got a
really tough hide on it.
I'm a little nervous.
I mean, it's a big weapon.
It's got a lot of
swinging power behind it.
But there's a lot
that could go wrong.
[music playing]
All right, Jonathan.
Let's talk about your
sword right here.
First up, it's sharp.
When wielding this weapon,
there is a nice balance to it.
Overall, your weapon,
sir, will kill.
Thank you.
Ed, are you ready?
I am.
I see him queuing up to
have a go at the pig.
I'm just like, please
don't break, please don't
break, please don't break.
[music playing]
All right, Ed.
Let's talk about your
weapon right here.
First up, I like the
leather wrapping that you
did right here on the handle.
It gives it a good grip.
Your blade is a little
bit on the heavier side.
But upon the swing, it lacerates
deeply into the carcass.
It will kill.
Gentlemen, this is
the dreaded bone chop.
Remember, this test
is all about what
the bones do to your
blades and not what
your blades do to the bones.
Ed, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Mm-hm.
[music playing]
Well, Ed, it's
all in one piece
but there is some chipping
on the blade here.
Oh, shoot.
The sword itself is heavy.
The handle is a bit
big for my hand.
All that being said, it
held up relatively well.
Well done.
- Thank you.
Jonathan, you're up.
You ready?
Hope so.
[music playing]
Well, Jonathan,
it's a similar result.
There is some edge
chipping here as well.
The handle being round on one
of the hits did roll in my hand.
Aside from edge chipping,
it held up very well.
Well done.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
To test the sharpness
of your blade,
I'll be cutting
through these pumpkins.
We'll take a look at those
cuts, see how clean they are.
Jonathan, you're up.
Are you ready?
Ready.
[music playing]
Nice.
Jonathan, you
can see your blade
has such a flexibility to it.
And when it hit, the
blade actually warped
out, cut over and through.
It's a heck of a cutter.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right.
Ed, you're up.
Are you ready?
I'm pretty confident going
through the pumpkin slice
because a pumpkin is a lot
softer than cow fingers.
[music playing]
All right, Ed.
That's a good clean
cut on that pumpkin.
You kind of see what happened.
I started compensating
for the weight
and pulled up and through.
The weight factor
in me using it is
an issue, but definitely sharp,
definitely a good cutter.
Well done.
Jonathan and Ed, the
judges have finished
their deliberation and there
can only be one "Forged in Fire"
champion.
And that champion is Jonathan.
Congratulations.
You are our new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Ed, your sword
didn't make the cut.
David Baker is going
to tell you why.
Ed, you brought us a
well crafted and beautiful
looking weapon.
But the oversized handle
and the extra weight
made that weapon
difficult to wield.
And at the end of the
day, this competition is
about making the best weapon.
Ed, please
surrender your blade.
ED: I agree with the
judge's decision.
His blade was more usable.
There is a big part of me
that wanted Jonathan to win.
There's a bigger part of me that
wanted me to win, of course,
but I'm really happy for him
because he's a great guy.
I made a good blade, he made
a little bit better blade.
No matter what, I'm
still a happy cat.